[Música]
olá meu nome é fabiane eu tenho 11 anos
e aí vou falar sobre criatividade e
gansos intabilidade pessoas de educação
antes de começar o meu tema vamos
entender um pouco mais
você sabia que anualmente consumiam
cerca de 500 mil toneladas de garrafas
pet isso é igual a 26 mil aviões e 83
mil elefantes e as caixas onde a vida
para quem não sabe as causas da vida são
caixas de suco leite tetra o produto e
ela fica um serviço mais tempo quando
essa consumidas no país todo ano 250 mil
toneladas em cts klagenfurt
pouco acima 50% das garrafas pet são
recicladas menos de 30% das caixas longa
vida são recicladas e reduzir esses e
reduzimos esse volume de lixo e se
reduzirmos volume de chuva pessoas não
seria ótimo o que pode ser feita só
coleta ou possa vir a reutilização podem
ser feitas diversas coisas como os jogos
brinquedos e materiais educativos
aqui estão alguns exemplos de brinquedos
e materiais educativos
minha avó marília todos no final da
semana é a agenda todas as sucatas ela
para o nosso clube pois lá a um lugar
onde as pessoas respondeu utiliza um
lixo criando várias coisas
esta é a quantidade de acessos à sucata
aquela junta e leva para o nosso clube e
podem transformar em diversas coisas
como gestor de garrafinha é muito
simples de fazer
o mais importante é a garrafa de resto
que não é reutilizável você usa ipi e
cola uma das minhas bandas preferidas
também ela também ensinou a fazer
aqui o mais importante é que você
recicla e não sei se vocês sabem do ano
retrasado também saiu uma notícia de uma
mulher que ela o lixo de um ano dela era
mais ou menos uma sacolinha desse
tamanho ela eu te levo ela se utilizava
todo o seu lixo tem exceção
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]